'LL GESTSERATS, AS
WE SAID,HEY'RET
TH ING CLIMATE
ALTHCA, IN S
HOUR OF CONSIDERING AMENDMENTS
THESS BETE MAJORITY LEHUCK
MOERICANS.
COMPREHEPAFUS NGRE HS.
THORO TO
MEDICATIONFOTRUGGLINSTEMSEY
AMAN RESANL.WEE .1NCREASGAU ICA
AMOP THE MADNETE NO.
E  KNOWN AS N INCLUDESARLY0 BI
CLIMATE AN
AEDTOG , CAPSEDICARPOCKET,000T.
>> CNN CHIEFGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDEN
L LOOKH ANNGLY SO.
WO N CAPITOL HILL
TES TH
OI T
TODAY, BUT I D
CODET SEEMS OCN THE SENATEOW SE
RS GOING
DERYONQUESTION, BUT I'
ASKING THAT QUESTION TO PRET SEE
BE MD THSE AMBER. ANCE TBUHAVE
NONEE.
UNDER THE RULES OF THE SENATE,
U ENTS
AS YOU WANT, GO AS LWA T,
DE, OF THIBI
BECAUSE OF THECE
WE BUDGET P THAOYINHEWHICH RYI
BE FILIBUSTEIS IS WHSO
F THEY KEEP THR CAUCUS IN L
ANNAR ANY ENENANLIMIT, A BUNCH O
S HOURS TO ,  HT , WOE 19T VOT0
SO,NO.Y TO
PAT TI ARE IINIFICAN
YEAR OFL PARTG.
THE LLO E MANAGED TO FENOFAN AT
AFTER THE NETS GO AFTE, THE WHO
CAUSE THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TRYIN KEE
L FORWARD THAT WOULDLOW MEDIRE
TIE TION DSO
IMPOSEOR MINIMUM
TAX, EXTEND ARACSUBSIDIES FOR T
NS OINAT HAS BEEN A KEPA
THAT M TT AT THELS  JTHATBLICANU
PLAN T AERE, IS NOT IN DOUBT,DE
SOMETIMEAYO
>> W K BUT THE
I'M SUPPOSED TO ASK YO Y TIMELIN
HORMOF PASSES IS BILL, WHEN IT
CAN YOU ALSO TALWHT
S  B LIKE A SCEN
A ZOMBIE MOVIE ONOT?orter: THEY.
THE LAST T THIS SESSION, THE FI
YEAR IN SOMTI
E LOOKING LIKE
NG HAALLINGP,
C.IS MUC
LIKHOUR
YSTORS ARE UP NG,
DIALKING AND 'S WHY VOTERS HAVE
TIME USSITTING IN THEIR SEATS .
E COFFENOEE, NO SLEEP, JUST WAG
STILLL
THE Y'BACKAYT,OUSE
IS A MUCH DIFFEREN
THONTH
TEPRES
THADS
MANU RAJU, YOU'RE THTH Y JOININS
FOR
WASHINGTON POST."
G WITH
, CALLED
TO SELL
, I TO REDUCE N.
PROVISIONS IN THE  TTUALLY HP ?
VISIONS,  CE CLIMATE
MORE PLENTIFND TERGY COSTS.LSO
ELECTRLIANL SORTS OF TAX THAT WE
HOMENDX  UTILL RTS OFNISWITCH TR
AND THEN INK OTHAT DEMOCRATS ARI
RE LOOKING AT CARESO, YOU KNTHEB
CARED E, NGEDEGOTIATE
RIPTION --
L COMP
AND SOHEREBY,  TH IS WHATIFOSE .
HOWTS SL IT.
CO SG,OK, THISSPBI OBVIO.5Y ON E
BUT WITHT ENDING
INFLATION? ISO WISORT OT
ADROUGH.
EV PO WAS THE
D THERE HAS BEEN SOMATION THATUW
DIFFERENT.
TH TRELYINEACCOUNTS AND  ANDS,
ENONNITURE OR THOSE THINGS THAG.
CEO CORPORATIONS TCERTAIN TYPEOF
OF ENERGY INVESTMENT ITHE HENDEO
GOING TOE INFLATIOE SAME WAY TH
NA HAS BEE
ME OE NS AIMWERING
PRICEHESE PROVISIONSDI TO T IS
E  AMERICANS S LMPIEN  TS AND A5
N.SO, I MEAN WHAT IS T O SUPPOR?
>>, I IHIE NEWS THAT WERD OVERE
THAT THE DEMOC H IN PLTHTY, POLW
AC ALEING LIMITS AND
HAVI MEDNT NEGTEDRUG
MIDTERMS,
PESON THAT
ISIFFICU
THEY'RE
TR THE SE D THE HOASS BILLBLPOT
P ESECARE
THE REPUTATION ATH, YOOW
THE FOS.
SOMEESE CLY  OR
ASOWS POLITICALLY  BUT
CERTAINLY THCAREPROVISIONS ARE